مؤخرا باتت روسيا تكثف من نشاطاتها في
القاره السمراء ليس فقط على المستوى
السياسي او حتى الاقتصادي لكن كذلك ايضا
على المستوى العسكري سواء عن طريق صفقات
اسلحه مع بعض الدول الافريقيه او حتى عن
طريق قوات فاجنر التي باتت تنتشر الان في
عدد من دول القاره السمراء هذا في ظل
انسحابات اوروبيه وتحديدا فرنسيه بعد
الاعلان عن انتهاء عمليات برخان في دول
الساحل والصحراء لكن ما تداعيات هذه
المنافسه ولماذا هناك ترحيب من بعض الدول
الافريقيه بتنامي الدور الروسي مقابل
تقليص الدور الاوروبي هذه اسئله سنطرحها
الان على المستشار الامنيه السابق للامم
المتحده في القرن الافريقيه السيد غسان
شبلي اولا السيد غسان اهلا بك وشكرا على
وجودك معنا يعني في البدايه لماذا تحرص
روسيا في هذه المرحله اعلى تعزيز وجودها
العسكري في بعض دول القاره الافريقيه
شكرا لكم ويسرني ان اكون معكم روسيا تحاول
حاليا استعاده بعض نفوذها في افريقيا
النفود الذي فقدته سابقا وخاصه بعد انهيار
الاتحاد السوفيتي اذ كان لروسيا سابقا
وجود قوي على الصعيد الامني والعسكري
والاقتصادي ناهيك عن التدريب والتعليم لكن
روسيا الان وبعد كل ما تعرضت له من عزله
بسبب الغرب تحاول ان تجد لنفسها موطئ قدم
من جديد في بعض الدول الافريقيه من خلال
تعزيز العلاقات العسكريه وبيع السلاح
الروسي وفي الوقت ذاته تكسب موقفا
دبلوماسيا للحصول على دعم لها من اجل
الوقوف في وجه بعض الاجراءات الدوليه التي
يفرضها الغرب وهذه مقاربه دبلوماسيه
لتتمكن من مواصله اعمالها وبرامجها
محاوله كما فعلت سابقا في فتره الاتحاد
السوفيتي لكن مصطفى غسان الملاحظ بان
روسيا تعزز مكانتها الان في بعض الدول
الافريقيه عن طريق قوات شبه نظاميه مثلا
قوات فاجنر لماذا تلجا روسيا الى هذه
الاستراتيجيه ولا يعني تقوي علاقاتها مع
هذه الدول عن طريق علاقات عسكريه رسميه
هناك جانبان للوجود الروسي الاطراف
الممثله للدوله وتتمحور في العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين الحكومات وهذه العلاقات
نراها مع الدول الافريقيه الكبيره مثل
اثيوبيا والسودان بينما الدول الافريقيه
ذات الحكومات غير المستقره او الانظمه
السلطويه فان ذلك يتم عبر منظمات غير
حكوميه مثل مجموعه فاجنر ووجود مثل هذه
الجماعات المسلحه يهدف ايضا لتامين بعض
الموارد الطبيعيه مثل الذهب للاستفاده منه
في تمويل روسيا كما نعلم فان روسيا تعاني
من عقوبات متزايده من المجتمع الدولي ما
يصعب عليها الوصول الى الانظمه المصرفيه
وبالتالي تبقى الثروات الطبيعيه مثل الذهب
مهمه لتمويل عملياتهم المتواصله
تمام طيب السيد غسان لسنوات كانت اوروبا
حاضره في كثير من الدول الافريقيه لكن منذ
الانقلاب في مالي حدث تحول وبات هناك شبه
توافق في بعض دول القاره الافريقيه
وتحديدا في دول الساحل والصحراء بانهاء
الوجود الاوروبي وتحديدا الفرنسي مقابل
وجود روسي لماذا هذا التحول في مواقف هذه
الدول وفي مواقف القائمين ويعني حكومات
هذه الدول
هذا سؤال جيد علي هنا ان اذكر ميليشيا
فادنر حيث ان رئيسها من اكبر المؤثرين في
الدعايه المضلله وما تفعله روسيا هو
محاوله مواجهه الاعلام الغربي والامريكي
من خلال تسجيل حضور متزايد على الارض وفي
هذه الحمله ادعائيه استخدمت روسيا لغه
التذكير بالاستعمار حيث انما يمس هذه
الدول الافريقيه هو استذكار حقبه
الاستعمار وبالتالي ما نشهده هو ارتباط
هذه الدول الافريقيه هذا الخطاب المضاد
للغرب خاصه مع وجود بعض الفصائل المسلحه
في بعض هذه الدول الافريقيه مثل مالي
وجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى وفي بوركينا فاسو
التي بدات تنتفض ضد انظمتها ولتعزيز قواهم
يلجاون لمثل هذه الجماعات المسلحه
يعني على مدى سنوات كانت هناك تحذيرات من
تنامي الجماعات الارهابيه في افريقيا لكن
الان يعني هناك هذه العلاقات ما بين بعض
الدول الافريقيه وروسيا برايك الى اي مدى
يعني ستؤثر هذه العلاقه على هذه الجماعات
يعني هل ستتقلص هذه الجماعات ام ستتنامى
بعد تنام العلاقات ما بين بعض الدول
الافريقيه وروسيا
على مدى السنوات الاخيره كانت معظم
العمليات في منطقه الساحل ضد التنظيمات
الارهابيه مخصصه فقط لمكافحه الارهاب ولم
تكن سياسه طويله الامد كما لم نشهد تحولا
كبيرا من حيث خفض الوجود الارهابي في
منطقه الساحل وهذه الجماعات الارهابيه
ستبقى نشطه وفاعله في المنطقه مستخدمه
علاقاتها لمواصله عملياتها وكسب التاييد
ليس لدينا وجود عسكري روسي هنا بالتالي
تبقى هذه التنظيمات الارهابيه محافظه على
عدم استخدام لغه ان القوات الروسيه هي
قوات مستعمره غازيه بل يتحدثون عن المزايا
العسكريه للوجود الروسي ولا اظن اننا سنرى
اثرا يذكر لذلك على عمليات التنظيمات
الارهابيه لطالما كانت هناك عمليات
لمكافحه الارهاب عندما طيب فيما يتعلق
بمساله الاسلحه الروسيه الكثير من الدول
الافريقيه لسنوات منذ حتى الاتحاد
السوفيتي التي يعني الذي ذكرته سابقا كانت
تعتمد على الاسلحه السوفيتيه والان تعتمد
على الاسلحه الروسيه الان هناك عقوبات
غربيه على موسكو بسبب الحرب في اوكرانيا
هل تعتقد بان هذه الدول ستواجه مشكله في
مساله الاعتماد على الاسلحه الروسيه
هذا يختلف حسب كل دوله روسيا اكبر مصدر
للسلاح لافريقيا اليوم اذ تستورد افريقيا
44% من اسلحتها من روسيا فمن الصعب تغيير
السلاح وخطه التسلح فان كان سلاح الدوله
روسيا يصعب التغيير لسلاح اخر لذلك لا بد
من تغيير المنظومه العسكريه كامله سنرى في
المستقبل القريب باستمرار لهذا الاعتماد
خاصه مع سهوله الوصول للسلاح الروسي ورغبه
روسيا في التعاون مع تلك الحكومات
الافريقيه وبالعوده لحاله فاجنر فان روسيا
توفر بعض الامن على الارض بشكل غير رسمي
وفي المقابل تجمع الذهب والسلع الاخرى
والتبادل التجاري مع تلك الدول قد نرى في
بعض هذه الدول رغبه في شراء السلاح الروسي
مقابل سلع معينه اما الدول التي في طريقها
نحو الاستقرار ونحو التحول الديمقراطي فقد
تبدا هذه الدول بالتحول ايضا نحو مشتريات
الاسلحه التقليديه ولكن هذا ايضا يعتمد
على درجه تيسير مبيعات السلاح من اوروبا
وامريكا
من بين هذه الدول ليس لديها ما تخشى
فيما يتعلق بالولايات المتحده وروسيا
دائما ما كان هناك يعني شبه تنافس او يعني
يعني احتدام في العلاقه ما بين روسيا
والولايات المتحده لكن الان تصاعدت يعني
هذه الحده في المنافسه وكذلك في المواجهه
احيانا ما بين روسيا والولايات المتحده
بعد الحرب في اوكرانيا الان ما هي
الخيارات المطروحه على طا
لمواجهه التمدد الروسي في القاره
الافريقيه التي تتحدث واشنطن دائما عن
انها منطقه استراتيجيه بالنسبه لها على
مستوى العالم
تماما هناك مناطق ليست ذات اهميه لامريكا
مثلا جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى فلا وجود
امريكيا ملحوظا فيها بل ما نراه هو ظهور
روسيا ودخولها لملئ ذلك الفراغ في حين
هناك دول اخرى لامريكا فيها مصالح
استراتيجيه رئيسيه وهناك سنرى اجراءات
مغايره اذ ستتعاون امريكا مع الحكومات
وتستخدم ادوات مثل العقوبات لمواجهه
الوجود الروسي لكن كما قلت الامر يعتمد
على كل حاله على حده ولا يمكن التعميم هنا
شاهدنا في ديسمبر استضافه امريكيه للقمه
الامريكيه الافريقيه حيث حضر معظم القاده
الافارقه وحاولوا التاثير من خلال نشر
مفاهيم الحوكمه الحكيمه وحقوق الانسان
كذلك النمو الاقتصادي والصحه وكل ما يشكل
اهميه للدول الافريقيه لان هذه الدول تشهد
تزايد في الاستقرار وبالتالي ستحتاج
الوصول الى الاسواق العالميه خلال اشهر
وفي يوليو تحديدا سيستضيف بوتين قمه روسيه
افريقيه وسيحاول فيها بوتين جمع اكبر عدد
من القاده الافارقه للتاثير على سياساتهم
قد نشهد تنافسا على الصعيد السياسي ولكنه
اخف على الصعيد العسكري لعدم وجود حضور
عسكري روسي في افريقيا وليس لها اي قواعد
عسكريه هناك بينما للاميركان قواعد عسكريه
في ارجاء القاره الافريقيه قاعده عسكريه
كبيره في جيبوتي اضافه الى وجود عسكري
متفاوت في دول اخرى وهذا ليس متاحا لروسيا
التنافس هو فعليا على النفوذ السياسي وهذا
ما سنراه
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا على وجودك معنا وعلى ما
تفضلت به من توضيحات السيد غسان شبلي
المستشار الامني السابق للامم المتحده في
القرن الافريقي شكرا جزيلا